essen verbindet nicht nur mich und
mittlerweile mehr als eine million von
euch mein essen verbindet familien
freunde und paare ich meine was gibt es
schöneres als mit seinem partner
gemeinsam zu sitzen einen entspannten
abend und ein gutes essen zu genießen
genau das wollte dir einen zufälligen
pärchen möglich machen aber weil ich
kein restaurant habe muss sich etwas
einfallen lassen wie schaffe ich es
mitten in der kölner innenstadt ein
romantisches dinner entstehen zu lassen
ist doch eigentlich ganz einfach das
ganze soll in einem lieferwagen
stattfinden also brauchen wir einen
lieferwagen zack lieferwagen gemietet
das dinner aber in einer romantischen
atmosphäre stattfinden soll und nicht
auf einer kahlen ladefläche brauchten
wir licht ein teppich einen tisch stühle
pflanzen ein bild musik und vieles
vieles mehr wir haben das nötigste
eingepackt und uns einer der
schwierigsten aufgaben des tages
gestellt mit einem riesigen lieferwagen
einen parkplatz in der kölner innenstadt
zu finden so supergroup liegt hier im
park dahin für dieses auto älter ja noch
ein bisschen nur der wagen steht jetzt
muss gekocht werden als vorspeise gibt
es eine cremige tomaten gruppe das
hauptgericht sind frische spaghetti mit
selbst gemachtem basilikum pesto und
cremiger berater als dessert mache ich
ein klassiker süßsaure lernen bass
schnell zubereitet und eigentlich immer
ein erfolg um all das jetzt gebührend zu
präsentieren brauchte ich nur noch eine
menükarte das menüs vorgekocht und der
lieferwagen steht bereits jetzt müssen
wir nur noch einrichten und es kann
losgehen
[Musik]
ein bisschen musik wir müssen die musik
die wir an spielen werden
[Musik]
ihr merkt hier ist was los eine letzte
sache fehlt noch
willkommen zum freiwild dinner
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass unsere leute habt ihr
hunger hier beiden ihr seht zu hause als
könntet ihr ein schönes steak vertragen
seid ihr zusammen perfekt gemacht vorne
seht ihr den silbernen lieferwagen da
will ich euch einmal hin werden stellt
gerne mal kurz teure fahrräder haben wir
keine überraschung für
aaron ramsey
das auch schon mal ein video gesehen
wenn wir doch schon angekommen wird ist
hätte nicht besser laufen können die
sind nicht nur ein paar leuten was essen
gehen sondern sie kommen auf meine
videos finden wird viel korrekt und ich
freue mich einfach heute passt alles
förderkonzept
so meine lieben ich freue mich euch zu
eurem freiwild dehner begrüßen zu dürfen
ich komme gern rein dem platz
so habe ich ihnen die akten nehmen
wie gesagt nehmen gerne platz macht sich
gemütlich durch ganz europa in dieser
riesigen kamera
[Musik]
erst mal was für den durst dadurch
beiden einschenken
ich will nicht brennt er ich bin noch
nicht so geübt als kenner und das für
beide etwas wein sein die genießer merkt
ihr schaut die richtigen kanäle würde
jetzt irgendwas zum wein sagen aber ich
weiß nichts darüber werden wir die
letzten vorbereitungen machen einfach
mal die tür zu sagen könnte mal ein
bisschen für euch sein soll das
basilikum schon direkt mal vorbereiten
weil das ein bisschen dauert hier alles
setzen wir direkt mal den nächsten
kochplatz auch auf 4 2 schon direkt weil
es geht hier alles schlag auf schlag die
tomatensuppe wird wieder heiß hier
drüben kocht langsam das nudelwasser
freue mich diesen beiden netten
herrschaften so einen schönen tag machen
können hoffentlich vielleicht gefällt in
der besucher überhaupt nicht jeden fall
das publikum interessiert sich auch so
dann kann auch schon
aufgetragen werden
wer die resolution würde ich mir die
türe öffnen das ist ja hier eine cremige
vegane tomatensuppe als starter für euch
beide schmeckt der wein ist es soweit
alles angenehm ansonsten kann ich euch
gerne das panorama fenster öffnen falls
ihr dann noch mal was wir sehen wollen
die besonderheit ist wie gesagt dies
komplett legal wir haben keine kosten
geschaut die erste reihe für euch und
ich glaube dann könnte jetzt noch mehr
genießen lasst euch schmecken ich komme
direkt in den zweiten gang jetzt ist
deine chance die fertig zu machen also
ja nicht an die sehr sehr lecker diese
[Musik]
welle gemacht wie vorhin super leckere
suppe ich habe auch sehr gut gelegen was
von meiner mutter einmal sender
und artikulieren sondern gemeinden wir
wollen ein pärchen so wir meinten wir
wollen junge leute im idealfall leute
die man soweit ich habe jetzt die mio
geknackt und wo man was zurückgeben kann
und zone und jetzt seid ihr einfach
bekommen ihr habt ihr noch bock auf
einfachen auf der speisekarte steht
selbst weiß gar nicht ob ich noch sehen
will wenn die mich vielleicht schlecht
bewertet wir haben so nudeln kochen
duden sind fertig so die dame appetit
habe ich gehört es gibt aber auch noch
im dezember sei so so ist gut aber ob
das paar muss ich mal sagen dass wir
freuen uns und die kamera freut sich auf
selbstgemachtes pesto dann ein wenig
frisches olivenöl noch drüber
alles klar und direkt serviert zurzeit
für den hauptgang ich habe zugehört die
ab sommer um die berater sollte gleich
ganz schön fließen
nein ich glaube nicht soll ich
vielleicht noch ein foto von euch machen
als andenken
ja wir weitwinkel oder sieht der oberarm
gleich noch grösser als oder ich gehe
noch mal ein schritt zurück dass man
auch sieht was sie eigentlich ist
[Musik]
oder man ist so im film ein check das
gar nicht mehr was haben wir hier heute
auf die beine gestellt alter heute
feiert einfach nur happy wenn ich
wirklich hauptspeise ist trainiert
worden und ist mit ihren lehrern zeller
und ich selber die einen halb leeren der
liebe handelt sich noch was hat ihm
nicht gefallen nur die portionsgröße
oder rauszufinden
positionsgröße aber das
wollte ich auch
also mein erster über das die pasta
flächen tick zu hoch also ich kann
zwischen kommen aber im laufe des essens
abständen gemerkt in kombination mit der
training pesto und dem zerschmolzen
berater hat dass er ganz ganz gefangen
nehmen bis gegeben im mund geschmack das
beste so gut geschmeckt wenn ihr beiden
das sagt dann ist das wohl so und hat
nicht ganz gereicht ich passe einfach
ein das fällt mir im gelernten felder
direkt auf ist schon platz fürs dessert
oder sogar noch im moment ist es ok so
dann kann's losgehen torte al limone ist
ja mehrfach neuen namen auswählen weil
schon zum dritten mal etwas machen
aber auch wieder ordentlich zulangen
jetzt müssen wir das ganze noch ein
schönes stücke schneiden zu schande dass
ich dazu keinen kaffee servieren kann zu
mir ein bisschen weh dass ich schon so
weit ist aber derzeit ist es her
ehrenmann guck mal wir kriegen ja noch
support pohl weil wir schon so lange
offen beim wenn ich danke dir danke
supporter all i wanna mit frischer minze
ich weiß nicht was kenner dann immer
sagen aber ich sage lasst euch schmecken
bekommen jetzt natürlich ausgleichen
können
[Musik]
so ein lieber das dessert ist
aufgegessen ich bin gespannt wie das
ganze bewertet hast aber ich hoffe
erstmal dass die beiden eine schöne zeit
hat das mega ist abgefangen ja wie lange
seid ihr jetzt viereinhalb stunden sind
sondern richtig ist aber
hat spaß gemacht japan freue ich mich
ich bin froh dass es euch beide
getroffen hat last but not least der
zitronenkuchen sich kenner des videos
aber auch sagen die gemacht deswegen war
ich umso gespannter wie es dann auch
schmeckt am besten fand ich den mix aus
der säure und dem der süße und hat ein
stockbett abgeholt mit dem eigenen
geschmack von dem unterboden ich würde
sagen sollte danke dass ihr bei diesem
wahnsinnigen video dabei war und wir
sehen zunächst wieder macht's gut bis
dahin tschüss